في منتصف ابريل نحن غبنا عنكم في برنامج
صباح العربيه لتغطيه الاحداث في السودان
هذه التطورات ما زالت تستحوذ على اهتمام
كبير دوليا وعربيه احداث طبعا نقلها
مراسلون من على الارض في السودان شاهدوا
معها قصصا انسانيه هذه القصص دائما ما
تتنوع وسواء من ضحايا الاشتباكات عمليات
نزوح عمليات اجلاء انقطاع في الكهرباء
والماء ايضا وصولا الى تعطل المشافي ونقص
المواد الطبيه وكذلك التموينيه يعني واحنا
غطينا
بنحب انه يعني نلقي الضوء عليه من زاويه
مختلفه مما تعطينا معه في الاخبار طبعا
مشاهدينا مراسله صباح العربيه زميله
الريان الظاهر شاركت في تغطيه الاحداث في
السودان نستضيفها اليوم ونتحدث معها عن
تجربتها المختلفه بعد قليل
نريد ان نعرف ونستفسر اكثر ونرصد حركه
المواطن والحركه الشرائيه وللامانه نفذت
كثير من المواد الاساسيه وللاسف حتى
المياه المعدنيه بدات تنفذ من المبردات
ومن ارفف المحال التجاريه
بعض الارفف تبدو خاليه تماما يعني بعض
الارفف نفذت منها هذه المواد وصعوبه
استيراده
[موسيقى]
هذه البساط السفريه تتجه لمناطق مختلفه من
السودان يعني من الولايات وهذا بس تحديدا
يتجه الى القاهره
[موسيقى]
قصص صراحه صعبه وماساويه العيش هنا في
الخرطوم لا يطاق بالنسبه للكثيرين شوح
الوقود والمواد الغذائيه والتموينيه
من الخرطوم تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه
الريان صباح العربيه الريان الظاهر الريان
صباح الخير
واعلم انه هذه اوقات قد تكون اصعب اوقات
مرت عليك دائما لكن خلينا
نبين للمشاهد كيف هذا التحول ما بين ريان
اللي كانت مبتسمه وتطلع على الجمهور وهي
مبتسمه وان شاء الله هذه الابتسامه
ابتسامه التفاؤل دائما تكون موجوده الى
الريان اليوم اللي تغطي هذه الاوضاع التي
تعتبر خطيره اولا على سلامتها وكذلك مقلقه
على سلامه اهلها واصدقائها وناسها في
السودان
مرحبا عادل مرحبا راويه بدايه العوده
الحميده اللي براءه صباح العربيه يتوقف
البرنامج
ويعود احيانا لما يدور حول العالم من
احداث اخرها كانت حرب اوكرانيا وروسيا لم
اتوقع ولم اتخيل في يوم من الايام ان
يتوقف البرنامج
لنسبه لتغطيات في السودان الامر مختلف
بالنسبه لي ووقعه ايضا مختلف لكن بالمقابل
يكشف ايضا معدن تيم وطاقم برامج صباح
العربيه هذه الاسره الواحده والمتماسكه
والمترابطه جدا التي تالم فيها فرد تداعى
لكم الجميع
بالمحبه والدعم وتلك الجميله الوريفه
مراسله صباح العربيه لدى حجازي التي فتحت
ابواب بيتها افتراضيا وكانما استقبلتني في
مصر الاوضاع هنا عادل يعني صعب للغايه
وابداها من هذا المباشر الذي انا عليه
الان لا استطيع الوصول
لموقع التصوير لزملائي بموقع التصوير نسبه
لما يدور في الشارع السوداني الشوارع ليست
الثامنه على الاطلاق ايضا
جحا الوقود ومقله وندره الرحالين هذه
الظروف لا تحيط انا فقط بل من يسكنون
ولايه
من المناطق التي بها اشتباكات طيب ريان
احكي لنا اكثر عن تفاصيل الحياه اليوميه
خلال هذه الفتره اللي مضت تقريبا ثلاث
اسابيع او اسبوعين ونصف من هذا الوضع
الصعب جدا في السودان كيف عشتوا عشتيه انت
مثلا ليس كمراسله ولكن ايضا كمواطنه هل
كان في احداث اثرت فيك مشاهد اثرت فيك مما
رايتي
يعني اولا نستيقظ على دوري المدافع هذا
بحد ذاته رعب كبير يعني واصوات لم نعتاد
عليها ملامح الشارع السوداني تغيرت تبدلت
تلك الشوارع التي كان بها نبض وروحه بها
قصص ملهمه الان لم تعد كسابق عهدها راويه
المرافق والمستشفيات المرافق الصحيه
البنوك ايضا المصارف المدارس
والكثير من ملامح الشارع السوداني
وتداول ايضا رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
يعني الحرب لم تكن مضره فقط بالانسان ايضا
الحيوانات تضررت يعني تداول رواد مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي خبر تضرر معهد التاريخ
الطبيعي ذاك المعهد العريق الذي يعود
للعام 1918
وتم تاسيسه في العام 1958
يعني منذ اندلاع الحرب لا احد يعتني
بالحيوانات هذا المعهد التاريخي الكبير
يهدف ايضا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات